i want you to meet the drew crew mega
makeover team
please welcome friend of the show and
celebrity hairstylist chris appleton
[Applause]
oh my gosh we i'm so happy to be with
chris oh you work with um jennifer lopez
kim kardashian
a few people in hollywood but i'm here
today to make over real women which is
what i love this is where it all started
one for me like making real women
looking feel great so it's gonna be a
good one all right now we're gonna bring
in the founder of harlem's fashion row
it's also a friend of the show brandeis
daniel
you know i have just been cyber stalking
you so much because i just love your
prolificness and i have such deep
admiration for you and i'm just so glad
that you're a part of today i'm so
excited to be a part of the today the
women are amazing
oh my god
all right
we also have beauty expert
extraordinaire my very dear friend
friend of the show and co-founder of
milk makeup it's santa roberts rusty
[Applause]
how fun is this
i mean
we've all done the show together before
but never like this are we really doing
25 people
zanna is mega you're just one of my
idols oh my gosh well that means so much
coming through because you were mine
also i am so proud to bring to the stage
instagram sensations the most
fashionable couple i know it's the young
emperors
[Applause]
tell everybody why you do what you do
because we're in love
mainly
and
we we chose that we weren't a team you
know in life and in any known work as
well well i just think again what you
put out into the world it's like you put
fragrance in the air oh that's so
beautiful it's true thank you it's
absolutely true okay zanna and the young
emperors are going to head backstage and
get to work
okay
[Applause]
and brandeis we're going to work with
you in just a minute okay but chris
you're up first okay
all right
let's get started
because
the biggest beauty questions that we've
ever been asked are going to be answered
today and let's ask our first beautiful
woman mariana
all right marianna what is your beauty
question okay with the pandemic i've
been nervous about going back to salons
and now my hair has gotten really long
really limp really dry
and i'd love to try bangs too but it's
like high maintenance and i don't want
anything that takes a long time to style
okay one of my options here i think for
me and for you i think what would really
work is like the curtain bang you sort
of trend which is really big right now
because it frames the face beautifully
it's called curtain bangs because they
basically are face framing layers that
sit around the face but what's nice
about them is it just kind of closes you
know the forehead a little bit once
again chris your instincts are brilliant
i'm not surprised
mariano
are you ready let's do this all right
let's take those things to the next
bubble
all right here we go
all right the next question a burning
beauty question that's gonna get
answered with expertise advice comes
from tina take a look
i love wearing jeans i want to level up
my denim can you help me dress up a
jeans look
[Music]
so brandes how common is this question
especially these days yeah so often we
think that jeans are just casual right
just for going up to pick up the kids
from school but you can really dress
james up you can wear a blazer with it
and it's so great because you can take
jeans from like a work day and then you
can go out with your friends and have
cocktails and have a good time so
they're so transitional all right well
tina's here with her new look and here's
a photo of tina and her jeans before
and let's see her now
[Applause]
what do you think and more importantly
how do you feel i feel so comfortable
and put together
everybody wants the perfect pair of
jeans and they styled it amazing
now brandis any tips with this outfit
that not only are we looking and liking
but that we can take away for ourselves
yeah absolutely so the white shirt is
underrated it is so underrated and then
we put on like a kitten heel with it and
she looks incredible like she actually
looks like the person that she is inside
right now
[Applause]
all right thank you so much
[Music]
all right now we're gonna go right over
to chris and mariana and check out her
reveal of the curtain bang here we are
oh hi
love it
all right guys so you can see i'm just
going to put a little bit of texturizing
spray but you can see we've not actually
done anything else to the rest of the
hair so this face framing here i just
think softens the forehead i think a
quick transformation without doing you
know an awful lot of work um you've not
seen it yet no
what do you guys think
[Applause]
[Music]
i am freaking out okay do you want to
see what you look like because i'm
freaking out absolutely all right chris
do you want to turn her around one
two three
[Applause]
how do you feel i love it oh my god
i love it
i love it so much it feels kind of just
like soft effortless natural will you
show her what it looks like with the
hair up yes
yes i got to tell you too like i get
really attached to my hair because i too
tried every hair under the sun
everything like no hair every color hair
perm
don't ever cut bangs with a cowlick and
get a perm on the same day i have never
had a bigger mental breakdown in my life
and
this is making me just rethink my hair
[Music]
thanks mariana i hope you're happy i'm
so happy thank you so much thank you
mariana
[Music]
you